il s'appelle kif alexander et la 68 ans
sont donc ne vous dit peut-être rien
mais il est bien connu des américains
il a dirigé la nasa 2005 à 2014 il a été
au centre des révélations et des douars
snowdon sur le programme de surveillance
illégal mis en place par l' agence de
renseignement américains le lanceur d'
alerte avait révélé alors que la nsa
surveillait non seulement d'autres pays
dont certains alliés mais aussi les
citoyens américains sur le sol national
et devinez quoi kif alexander vient
aujourd'hui de décrocher un poste en or
et pas n'importe où chez amazon il va
intégrer le conseil d'administration du
géant du commerce électronique
une annonce que n'a pas manqué de
commenter edouard snowdon depuis la
russie où il est exilé depuis sept ans
il s'avère que et alexa est le diminutif
de et alexander oui le 'case alexander
personnellement responsable des
programmes illégaux de surveillance de
masse et qui ont provoqué un scandale
mondial et amazon web services qui
héberge environ 6% de tous les sites web
6 % des sites sur la toile ça peut
paraître peu très peu mais quand on sait
la popularité et le trafic de certains
d'entre eux on se dit que les
conséquences peuvent être colossal parmi
ces sites on retrouve par exemple
instagram netflix ou et amazon bien sûr
depuis son départ de la nasa et qui fait
les grandes heures a fondé sa propre
société de cyber sécurité chez amazon
son nouveau job devrait aussi consisté à
récupérer le contrat cloud de 10
milliards de dollars déjà attribué à
microsoft par le département de la
défense
une question se pose malgré tout avec
l'arrivée de kif alexander peut-on
craindre une surveillance massif chez
amazon certains en tout cas se montre
déjà inquiets
chaque jour de grosses entreprises comme
amazon prennent de lourdes décisions
éthiques qui touche les vies des gens
sans aucune responsabilité démocratique
clairement il est inquiétant que l'on
place au coeur de tout cela une personne
qui a passé des années à défendre une
collecte secrète de données dont
l'illégalité a depuis été prouvée
et nous n'avons pas besoin d'une autre
et nsa même son de cloche sur twitter où
de nombreux internautes ont été surpris
par cette nomination de kif alexander
chez amazon l'ancien chef de la nsa
keith alexander rejoint le conseil
d'administration d'amazon pour rappel il
a été connu pendant la sphère des douars
snowden qui avaient révélé l'ampleur des
programmes de renseignement américains
je dis ça je dis rien
ce n'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour les
clients d'amazon
c'est tellement mauvais malheureusement
comme le dit le dicton toute chose et
tout le monde a un prix il est en effet
très rare de trouver la loyauté
l'intégrité et l'honnêteté de nos jours
amazon embauche l'ancien chef de la haye
nsa keith alexander en tant que
directeur surpris bien sûr que non d'un
côté on a celui qui a dirigé un
programme de surveillance qualifiée
d'illégale et potentiellement
d'anticonstitutionnel par la justice
américaine qui fait les grandes heures
est libre de ses mouvements en aucun cas
inquiété par les autorités et qui donc
obtient un poste haut placé dans l'une
des plus grandes entreprises de la
planète
de l'autre on a celui qui a révélé ce
programme au monde entier edouard
snowdon lui a quitté son pays son
travail ses proches et a dû s'exiler en
russie pour éviter d'être poursuivi pour
espionnage aux états unis où il encourt
30 ans de prison
c'est con marcherait presque sur la tête